es 19 de agosto y es momento de hablar
de temas económicos de este día
miércoles con la especialista daniel
hablando un ramírez daniela empezamos
con la policía de brasil pues arrestados
prominentes empresarios con relación al
caso la valla pto así es a la muy buenas
noches se trata de los hermanos o josé y
germán efromovich ambos son accionistas
de avianca holdings y aunque la
investigación no tuvo que ver con la
aerolínea sus acciones si se desplomaron
hoy en la bolsa de colombia más del 22
por ciento con lo que sí tiene que ver
la investigación es con supuestos
fraudes que habrían cometido en
contratos de navíos en el marco de esta
operación en la valla pto como se sabe
está la mayor operación anticorrupción
en la historia de brasil y al final del
libro derivó en el escándalo de
odebrecht todavía de mayores
proporciones y que ya se extendió por
toda américa latina
los hermanos efromovich son acusados de
haber pagado a través de su empresa y la
s a
son unos de más de 7 millones de dólares
a altos ejecutivos de transpetro que es
la filial de petrobras responsable del
transporte de combustible esto para
obtener contratos
serio público federal dice que por estas
transacciones las arcas públicas dejaron
de recibir unos 110 millones de dólares
daniela el precio del cobre está a punto
de tocar máximos históricos y hay un
país latinoamericano que está muy feliz
con esta noticia si alan hoy el precio
del metal en la bolsa de londres superó
la barrera de los 3 dólares por libra
este es su mayor precio desde junio de
2018 y el país que está de celebración
con esta noticia es chile cuya economía
se desplomó el 14 por ciento en el
segundo trimestre y le voy a decir
porque le interesa porque con una
producción de casi 6 millones de
toneladas al año esta nación produce
casi una tercera parte de cobre que se
consume en el mundo es decir es el mayor
productor del planeta su economía
también es muy dependiente de esta
operación minera pues de todo lo que
exporta al menos la mitad es del también
llamado metal rojo
el aumento últimamente en el precio del
cobre así como en el del oro tiene
nombre propio el dólar que a medida que
se va debilitando va impulsando a otros
activos conocidos como refugio
buenos otros temas daniela y es que
sobre la atención económica entre china
y australia desde cuándo viene este
pulso en los países de la disputa viene
de antes muy recientemente primero
beijing impuso aranceles a la cebada
australiana después suspende algunas
importaciones de carne de res luego les
dijo a los estudiantes y turistas chinos
que no era seguro viajar a ese país y
ahora es el vino el país asiático lanzó
una operación anti dumping que lo que
hace es investigar si australia está
llenándolo de vino barato en detrimento
de sus productores locales casi siempre
este es el primer paso a alan para
imponer aranceles la relación se ha
venido deteriorando últimamente y el
culpable tiene nombre y apellido el kobe
19 el país oceánico es uno de los que ha
acusado a china de propagar el virus y
ha pedido abiertamente que lo
investiguen
o nos ahora con varias noticias
relacionadas con las aerolíneas del día
de hoy daniela bueno para nadie es un
secreto que las aerolíneas son uno de
los sectores más afectados con la
pandemia en el caso de la alemana
lufthansa los medios locales reportan
que sus directivos llegaron a un acuerdo
con los pilotos para no despedirlo sino
hasta marzo de 2021 entretanto la
aerolínea más grande de américa latina-
latam reportó pérdidas en el segundo
trimestre por 890 millones de dólares y
volviendo al 'viejo continente' en
europa canceló las operaciones
comerciales que tenía previstas para
septiembre con origen y destino en cinco
países de américa latina lo hizo en
argentina bolivia colombia paraguay y
perú debido al cierre de los aeropuertos
en su lugar realizará vuelos semanales
de repatriación también hay otras
empresas como avianca en colombia en la
misma situación
aumento de escuchar los indicadores
económicos de esta jornada todos los
índices en wall street cerraron en rojo
y aquí les cuento una noticia de última
hora que seguramente dará de qué hablar
en la bolsa de nueva york y es que la
plataforma de alquiler vacacional el
bien vi anunció su salida a bolsa aunque
no dio mayores detalles en europa las
bolsas subieron luego de cuatro sesiones
seguidas a la baja y en américa latina
la bolsa de buenos aires borró la mitad
de las pérdidas de la jornada anterior
para finalizar daniela tu cifra del día
son los 2 millones de dólares de valor
en bolsa que alcanzó hoy apple
convirtiéndose en la primera empresa de
la historia de wall street y de eeuu en
hacerlo hace dos años esta compañía
costaba un billón de dólares alan es que
todos tenemos algún producto relacionado
a la mayoría de personas con esta gran
empresa muchas glass andén ya le ha
favorecido si la ha impulsado todavía
más muy bien daniela muchas gracias por
este recorrido económico gracias a
ustedes por su compañía siguen france24
[Música]